[Music]
when temperatures drop and snow covers
the Wyoming range lands like you see
here today livestock producers feed
harvested forage to their animals this
forage helps cattle sheep and other
domesticated livestock maintain body
condition and health winter can be a
stressful time for animals and humans
alike this is why livestock producers
monitor their animals energy
requirements the lowest temperatures
that livestock can tolerate before
needing a boost in fed energy is 20 to
32 degrees Fahrenheit these temperatures
are for dry livestock and do not include
windchill
if livestock are wet and/or it's windy
increased fed energy by one to two
percent for every degree the wind chill
temperature falls below that 20 to 32
degrees energy is most easily provided
through additional hay during summer and
fall alfalfa oats and grass are
harvested and stored in bales for
producers to feed their livestock a
needed boost in nutrients other than
wind chills and low temperatures deep
snow conditions may require livestock
producers to feed hay to their animals
supplementing rangeland grasses with bed
forages is a common practice in Wyoming
from the University of Wyoming extension
I'm ash the girls exploring the nature
of Wyoming
[Music]